en el vídeo anterior hablamos sobre el
átomo me emocione un poco sobre como en
el centro del átomo tenemos el núcleo el
cual es una fracción muy pequeña del
tamaño total del átomo y sobre el
electrón dijimos que aunque lo llamamos
partícula
puede ser descrito de mejor manera como
un tipo de burrón alrededor del núcleo y
que aunque es una partícula debido al
principio de incertidumbre de heisenberg
nunca podemos saber con exactitud en
cierto momento en donde está la
partícula y cuál es su momento
así que describirlo como partícula es un
poco extraño en mi opinión también
comentamos sobre la manera de
describirlo ya no decimos que una
partícula está en órbita como los
planetas orbitan alrededor del sol
en su lugar esto se describe como una
función de probabilidad alrededor del
núcleo así que si el núcleo está aquí
tenemos un orbital de hecho es el primer
orbital y hablaremos más sobre esto en
este vídeo será una esfera alrededor del
núcleo y de hecho la esfera no tiene un
límite o borde siempre que vean a
alguien dibujando lo ellos dirán que
éste
es en donde el electrón se encontrará el
90% del tiempo es allí donde marcarán el
límite dirán bueno esto estará dentro de
la esfera y realmente se volverá más
denso conforme se acercan al centro de
la esfera si ésta fuera una sección
transversal sería muy denso en el centro
y se volverían menos denso conforme se
van alejando de éste lo que significa
que hay una mayor probabilidad de
encontrar el electrón en el primer
orbital cerca del centro que es cerca
del borde aunque este punto en el borde
es algo artificial podemos encontrar un
electrón prácticamente en cualquier
parte aunque tiene una probabilidad
mucho menor de encontrarse afuera pero
hablaremos más respecto en el vídeo
ahora quiero regresar al modelo de board
y es bueno saber que fue llamado así por
news board y yo pienso que esta persona
no fue para nada un flojo al contrario
era sobresaliente en su campo y no fue
hace mucho quizás hace unos 100 años así
que estamos hablando de cosas que es
probable que encuentren documentos en su
biblioteca en donde no hace mucho las
personas debatían estos temas en el
modelo de por el cual modela los
electrones como planetas orbitando al
de una estrella o del sol fue un modelo
bastante útil al menos es útil para mi
cerebro le ayuda a conceptualizar la
idea de los estados de energía así que
este es un electrón alrededor del núcleo
se mueve alrededor de una órbita y
sabemos que y quiero recalcarlo las
órbitas no existen en el átomo los
orbitales son lo que ocurre recordamos
que los orbitales son solamente
funciones de probabilidad que describen
en donde es más probable encontrar un
electrón mientras que la órbita es una
manera tradicional y mecánica de
describir la ruta que sigue un objeto
clásico como un planeta alrededor de una
estrella no quiero mencionar demasiado
es tecnología pero si ven este modelo la
idea de los niveles de energía comienza
a tener sentido por ejemplo si tenemos
algo orbitando si tengo un planeta
alrededor de una estrella así y si fuera
a tener más energía quizás su órbita se
volvería más elíptica quizá por alguna
razón puse más energía a esto tuve un
empuje de cohete en este planeta ahora
que le puso más energía temporal en
lugar de seguir esta ruta quizás no
empuje
así y quizá esto lo acelerará un poco
más y quizá vaya de esta manera no no sé
no he hecho los cálculos pero en general
va a tener un poco más de energía
cinética así que irá un poco más lejos
del planeta y quizás si lo impulsó de
nuevo esta ruta se verá algo así su
órbita se empujará más lejos conforme se
acerca a esta estrella y de hecho
logrará más velocidad conforme se acerca
a esta estrella con gravedad aquí hay un
par de cosas interesantes algo obvio es
que este planeta o cohete que tiene esta
órbita tiene más energía
y este de aquí tendrá más energía que
digamos este otro de aquí y la energía
aún cuando estamos hablando del mundo
cuántico y este es solo una analogía
pues sabemos que las órbitas no se
aplican aquí pero la energía es la misma
energía en cualquier parte y la energía
es la habilidad de realizar un trabajo o
transmitir calor o crear calor así que
si no están haciendo trabajo alguno y
tiene la energía podrían tener un
desperdicio de trabajo al generar calor
hablaremos más al respecto en futuros
vídeos pero es la misma idea si yo
tuviera un paquete de cohetes y pusiera
algo de energía en esto o lo empujara de
alguna manera yo podría enviar esto a
una órbita más alta la idea de los
orbitales es la misma excepto que
obviamente estas no tienen estas rutas
bien definidas así pues conforme un
electrón tiene más energía esta energía
puede ser la edad al electrón
principalmente mediante ondas de luz u
ondas electromagnéticas que pueden
ponerse en el electrón y cuando veamos
mecánica cuántica veremos esto en más
detalle pero esencialmente si vemos la
luz como un conjunto de
a que este es como un conjunto de
fotones y un fotón golpea un electrón
que tiene cierto estado de energía de
pronto éste entrará en un estado más
alto de energía y quizá este irá a esta
distribución de probabilidad que es una
capa alrededor de esta otra y quizás si
después de que es excitado y estos son
términos que escucharán de los químicos
y los físicos aquí excitado significa
que la energía fue puesta en un electrón
y esto hizo que llegara a un estado de
energía más alto y quizás se podría
quedar ahí o podría regresar a su estado
de energía más bajo así que cuando
regresa a su estado más bajo de energía
donde estaba originalmente emitirá de
vuelta al fotón y es por eso que podemos
ver algunas cosas brillar pero
hablaremos de esto más adelante a lo que
quiero llegar es hasta este punto de
manera intuitiva porque lo que resta de
química y en mucho de física
escucharemos a las personas a hablar
sobre los estados de energía y este es
solo la idea general el electrón que
está en un orbital más alto porque se le
proporcionó energía podría querer
regresar a su órbita al más bajo
original ahora pueden preguntar cómo es
que un electrón puede
amanecer en ese orbital más alto qué tal
si hubiera hecho a otros dos electrones
en este orbital de aquí hablaremos un
poco sobre cómo es que se van llenando
los diferentes orbitales pero antes
quiero darles la noción intuitiva
digamos que tenemos dos electrones que
están por todo este lugar no podemos
localizarlos y después agregamos un
tercer electrón así que podríamos decir
que el estado de menos energía es esta
esfera interna de color magenta que
acabo de dibujar porque no podría estar
acá este tercer electrón bueno mi
intuición es que ya hay 12 electrones
ahí y aunque los electrones son atraídos
por el núcleo debido a que este tiene
toda la carga positiva este es repelido
por estos dos electrones así que se irá
al siguiente estado de energía quizás
llegue a esta capa de aquí y hay otra
cosa interesante respecto a los estados
de energía y esto es clave en química
cuando comencemos a hablar sobre
reactividad y como algo puede reaccionar
con otra cosa y por qué lo haría si
estás en estado alto de energía por
ejemplo si usamos la analogía de las
órbitas en este estado alto de energía
en el caso de los planetas que se alejan
del cuerpo al que están atraídos la
fuerza gravitacional se vuelve más débil
en el caso de los electrones cuando se
alejan más de un estado alto de energía
la fuerza colom se debilita las cargas
de las que hablamos cuando nos referimos
a electrones y protones esas son las
fuerzas coloma así que eso es una carga
negativa y entonces tenemos cargas
positivas en el centro pero conforme
esto se aleja la fuerza del núcleo se
vuelve más débil por lo que se vuelve
más fácil separarlo por completo es más
fácil quitarlo y quizá compartirlo con
otros átomos o quizá dárselo a otros
átomos y hablaremos mucho al respecto
cuando hablemos de enlaces pero quería
primero darles esta noción intuitiva la
siguiente pregunta que puede surgir es
cómo es que los electrones llenan los
diferentes orbitales y cómo se verían
dichos orbitales aquí estoy mostrando
varias imágenes de wikipedia aquí están
los diferentes orbitales y aquí tenemos
dos aspectos del orbital una es esta
capa esta capa de energía la cual está
dada por este número n esa es la capa de
energía y para qué
sepan todo esto encaja estas capas de
energía corresponden a periodos en la
tabla periódica así que un periodo de la
tabla periódica es literalmente un
renglón en ella por lo que este periodo
1 de la tabla periódica todo hasta el
helio es el periodo 1 es el primer
renglón eso significa que los elementos
que están en este primer periodo sus
electrones generan la primera capa de
energía por ejemplo el hidrógeno tiene
un solo protón y todo lo que hacemos y
aquí vamos a suponer que tenemos átomos
neutros por lo que podemos tomar lo que
aprendimos en el vídeo anterior que el
número atómico nos dice cuántos protones
tiene esto es cuántos protones hay en el
hidrógeno pero si suponemos que es un
átomo neutro podemos decir que este es
también el número de electrones así que
podemos usar el número atómico como
indicador de cuántos electrones hay en
un átomo neutro así que este tiene un
electrón a dónde va pues está en el
primer periodo el primer electrón va a
la primera capa de energía
queremos escribir la configuración
electrónica para el hidrógeno diríamos
que en el hidrógeno la configuración
electrónica está en la primera celda o
capa de energía en 1s y sólo hay un
electrón aquí y como luce esta primera
sub capa orbital esta capa s es una
esfera de hecho es lo que dibuje al
inicio del vídeo literalmente es una
esfera si fuéramos a dibujar un corte
transversal de esta se vería más densa
en el centro y se volvería menos densa
conforme nos alejamos de este en el
vídeo anterior les mostré cómo se veía
la función orbital del helio ustedes
vieron que era más oscura y más densa en
el medio y más escasa y gris conforme
nos alejamos del centro así que cuál es
la configuración de electrón del helio
en cada una de estas sub capas y seré un
poco más específica en el siguiente
vídeo debido a que me estoy quedando sin
tiempo aquí se pueden poner dos supongo
que en cada configuración geométrica
para cada sub capa se pueden poner dos
electrones y veremos esto con más
detalle en el futuro así que la
configuración para el helio está en el
primer periodo así que
1 s 2 en esta sub capa s dentro del
primer periodo o la primera capa de
energía tendrá 2 electrones aquí
fascinante y que hay de litio está aquí
también es el nombre de una canción de
un grupo llamado evanescence y creo que
es el nombre de esa canción de
evanescence porque se usa o se usaba
para tratar la depresión así que el
litio cuál es su configuración de
electrones el primer electrón va en 1s 1
el segundo electrón va en 1s 2 y cuando
digo primero o segundo me refiero a los
estados de energía por lo que el primer
electrón que israel en ese estado de
energía más bajo que está en ese uno el
segundo electrón también querrá estar
ahí y 2 los electrones caben en este
primer estado de energía o este primer
suv orbital o esta primera capa entonces
se vuelve 1s 2 ahora con el litio se
llenan los primeros 1s 2 se llenó la
primera capa de energía y esta primera
sub capa la cual tiene la forma s así
que ahora ese tercer electrón tiene que
irse a la segunda capa de energía y eso
funciona de manera pares
como lo he descrito debido a que está en
el segundo periodo el segundo periodo es
este que está aquí así que la
configuración electrónica será 1 ese 22
de sus electrones se ubicarán de la
misma forma que el helio y entonces ese
tercer electrón estará en 2 ese 1 es a
su configuración de electrones a qué me
refiero con 12 s 1 pues que el litio
tendrá 2 electrones en ese puntito que
sobreescribir y después a alrededor de
ese punto habrá otra capa la cual es la
segunda capa de energía y habrá un
electrón aquí permítanme ver si puedo
dibujar así que tendrán una esfera de
probabilidad donde quepan los primeros
dos electrones y si este fuera un corte
transversal sts el electrón va a estar
en la capa de probabilidad alrededor de
esa cuando dibujo esto no es que el
electrón vaya a estar exactamente en ese
orbital solo estoy dibujando en donde se
haría el corte donde decimos que hay una
probabilidad del 90% de encontrar un
electrón aunque este electrón podría
aparecer aquí
ya o por allá pero son lugares de muy
poca probabilidad mientras que aquí será
mucho más probable que se encuentre de
cualquier manera me estoy quedando sin
tiempo continuaré con esta discusión en
el siguiente vídeo y comenzará a hablar
sobre formas más extrañas que pueden
tomar los orbitales y quizá les daré una
noción de por qué estas formas en
realidad no son tan extrañas